ah kids these days ruining words for
everybody right now there's a very
popular meme going about the Internet
Netflix and chill what does that even
mean is it a verb is it a noun whatever
happened to just asking someone out to
dinner I'm going around today to ask my
co-workers if they in fact know what it
means to Netflix and chill let's go find
out someone were to text you and ask you
if you wanted to watch Netflix and chill
what do they mean
to Netflix and chill oh you want to hang
out they would like to watch Netflix in
charge Netflix in what chill and chill
sexual thing that I don't understand so
there's a popular meme going around
right now on the Internet where Netflix
and chill actually means someone's
inviting you over to have sexual
relations with them I stay away so
you're basically tricking her into like
coming over that's what this is I always
ask my friends to come over and watching
Netflix and chill there's a cyber it's
like cool I just want to hang out and
watch Netflix but it's like Netflix and
chill just means hey how would we come
over to my place make some ramen in this
like hook up it's essentially like hey
do you want to relax together it's the
best it works it works most of the time
if you were going to Netflix and chill
with someone what movie would you watch
like wait am I actually watching the
movie or something with lots of sexual
tension so I could just like put that
context probably onto the person I'm
thinking clueless king of the hill used
to be on net but I guess a movie that
you wouldn't want to watch you're not
gonna watching it anyway probably Josie
the Pussycats I'd be watching Frasier
not a movie I'd be watching Frasier so
what did we learn here today mm well I'm
still a little bit confused does it
really mean to just hang out and watch a
movie or does it mean I'm getting laid
tonight
it can mean different things to
different people comment below on what
you think it really means to Netflix
until until next time
one of the first times I like hooked up
with a girl really heavy we were
watching the movie se7en